[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute dreht sich alles rund um das thema
barbara weiß eigentlich eine gemüsesorte
wird aber oft für süßes benutzt also für
kuchen und marmelade oder auch für
rhabarber limonade
heute gibt es ab aber limonade und
rhabarber streuselkuchen und ich möchte
ich ein bisschen was über den rhabarber
erzählen
es gibt nämlich verschiedene sorten
einmal den rhabarber mit grünem
fruchtfleisch und grüner schale deshalb
sehr sauer enthält auch sehr viel
oxalsäure und menschen die zum beispiel
auch in empfindlichen magen haben oder
auch allergisch reagieren können
reagiert da wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
empfindlicher besser geeignet ist der
rote rhabarber mit roter schale und
rotem fruchtfleisch da ist aber bei der
ernte nicht so ergiebig und deswegen
auch etwas seltener verfügbar
am gängigsten ist dieser rhabarber hier
der hat nämlich eine rötliche schale ein
grünes fruchtfleisch sieht man auch hier
wenn man hier auf schneidet dass das
innere grün ist der ist leicht säuerlich
aber milder als der grüne rhabarber auf
jeden fall
und der muss auch ein bisschen geschält
werden der rote rhabarber eignet sich
vor allem gut fürs kuchenbacken weil man
den kauf schälen muss man muss nur die
holzigen enden so ein bisschen ab 10
jetzt könnt ihr hier den rhabarber
einfach mit einem messer abschälen also
gerade so ein bisschen dass die fasern
wechselt rhabarber gibt es übrigens so
etwa ab mitte ende april bis ungefähr
august nach august ist man den nicht
mehr weil einfach die oxalsäure zu hoch
ist und seine rechte ungenießbar und man
kann aber auch ganz gut einfrieren dafür
einfach stehlen
ein bisschen klein schneiden aufs
backblech legen und einfrieren und dann
erst verpacken wenn die stängel
eingefroren sind oder eingefroren sind
und dann können dass er wirklich
monatelang im free verlagern und habe
immer rhabarber auf vorrat
[Musik]
beim schälen merkt man schon dass der
rhabarber richtig saftig ist hier habe
ich jetzt den ganzen abfall wenn man den
roten rhabarber mit rotem fruchtfleisch
nimmt hat man einfach ein bisschen
weniger abfall und deswegen ist es
besser jetzt wieder geschnitten und muss
dann mit zucker bestreut werden damit
diese flüssigkeit aus dem rhabarber
rauskommt und den kuchen dann eben nicht
vermischt und aus dieser flüssigkeit
machen wir dann limonade
[Musik]
und ich gebe pro kilo rhabarber etwa 150
gramm zucker dazu das ist für mich so
die optimale menge dann wird der kuchen
und auch die limonade nicht so süß aber
auch nicht dessauer also ich habe ich
jetzt 1990 mit zucker drüber
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der deckel drauf und dann
kann ich es einfach in den kühlschrank
stellen
wenn es nicht so warm ist auch bei
raumtemperatur lagern und am besten ist
es wenn ihr das jetzt über nacht stehen
lassen damit wirklich der ganze
rhabarber saft raus kommt für den quark
öl teig verwende ich 450 gramm mehl vier
teelöffel backpulver 125 gramm zucker
eine prise salz 250 quark zweier etwas
vanille extrakt 200 milliliter milch und
60 gramm quark öl teig gibt es schon ein
grundrezept dafür werden jetzt alle
zutaten einfach kurz vermischt erste
trockenen und dann die flüssigen
[Musik]
der teig kommt jetzt in meinen backblech
das habe ich bereits eingestellt da habe
ich den bug rahmen drauf auf die größte
stufe eingestellt
und jetzt einfach ganz kurz verteilen
wir könnten auch ein bisschen flüssiger
machen mit etwas mehr mädels es kommt
einfach immer darauf an wie groß die
eier rahmen und die gleiche schlüssel
verwende ich jetzt würdigt streusel die
zutaten habe ich schon hier stehen für
die streusel verwende ich bei 125 gramm
mehl 2 teelöffel zimt 150 gramm zucker
eine prise salz 150 gramm butter und
wann ihr extrakt jetzt nehme ich einfach
die zutaten und verse auch in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt sie aber auch
zum beispiel mit den händen ein bisschen
verrühren oder auch ein handrührgerät
verwenden
total einfach ein bisschen klein machen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den rhabarber abgelesen
und in sanft unbedingt aufhören
daraus kann man nämlich rhabarber
limonade machen jetzt sieht man auch das
richtig schön gebessert hat und das
wasser kommt echt nur aus mokaba raus
[Musik]
jetzt kurz ausdrücken und dann direkt
auf den kuchen streuen und mit den
rhabarber nicht zu lange ziehen lassen
könnt wie ich dann verrät den rhabarber
am besten mit etwas stärker
das bindet dann einfach die flüssigkeit
unter kuchen wird nicht so matschig aber
ich finde version über nacht echt super
weil ich dann auch gleichzeitig eine
limonade habe
[Musik]
der rest und da kommen jetzt die
streusel drauf
und ab in den backofen
den rhabarber saft fühle ich jetzt in
einem gefäß und kann ein bisschen
limettensaft dazugeben und wenn ihr
möchtet dass der rhabarber saft ein
bisschen rosa wird dann fügt einfach
noch lebensmittelfarbe dazu oder ihr
nehmt einfach direkt in roten rhabarber
denn da ist die farbe schon perfekt
jetzt kann man das ganze einfach mit
mineralwasser und einzeln anrichten und
hat die perfekte erfrischende limonade
[Musik]
so frisch und sag ich euch und hier habe
ich jetzt einen blechkuchen einfach
klein geschnitten in kleine würfel
puderzucker bzw süßen schnee drauf
gestreut und dann in muffin förmchen
gesetzt so kann man nämlich den
blechkuchen einfach aus der hand essen
und ich find's einfach ein bisschen
hübscher vor allem wenn man den kuchen
mitnehmen möchte wir gehen jetzt auch
heute abend weg dann nehmen wir das so
mit und es ist echt schön handlich und
vor allem braucht man kein geschäft und
es ist schlecht richtig schön mit den
rhabarber stückchen kuchen schmeckt doch
total lecker und saftig weil sie das
rezept nach machen möchte dann schaut
auf meinem blog for business blog de da
findet ihr sowohl die limonade als auch
den kuchen ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachbacken und bis zum nächsten mal
bei dem schönen wetter noch ein bisschen
nach draußen
[Musik]